hey everybody last week of my tour
before I filmed my special in Chicago at
the Vic theater December 1st and 2nd
tickets are still available right now
for that you can get them on salano
comedy.com this is the last week I'm
performing this material tonight we're
in Appleton everybody how'd you guys
like the show
[Music]
tonight
[__]
folks Joe Roa here I am out on the road
doing those live shows all over the
place and uh let's folks Jo De Rosa here
I am out doing live show all over the
place by myself not with the Pod just
alone solo doing my thing uh first up
November 9th New York New York I'm doing
a special show this is a selected
readings I'm going to be reading entries
for my audio book The Penthouse papers
so plus plus some other stuff I've had
published over the years uh that's for
the New York Comedy Festival in New York
New York at the KGB bar on November 9th
November 11th Philadelphia PA theater of
the Living Arts almost sold out only a
few tickets left please come out to that
November 17th we're sold out Pittsburgh
PA at the bottle rocket November 18th
Buffalo New York theater at senica 1
again almost sold out buy your tickets
Please November 30th Denver Colorado at
the summit December 1st Phoenix Arizona
at the Crescent Ballroom December 3rd
Salt Lake City in Utah at the soundwell
and January 13th just announced New York
New York gramarcy theater folks new hour
popping off at the grammar seat and all
of those other venues I just listed with
the exception of the KGB bar show that's
the only one that's not me doing I never
promis You a Rose Garden I'm going to be
doing readings from the book at that
show and that show only Anyway come
check me out joa.com for all the show
info and your ticket links and as usual
if you're in New York please please
please come see us at Joey roses open 7
days a week at 11:30 a.m. every day
delicious sandwiches cheap drinks come
see us and if you want info about the
venue Joey roses nc.com what's up guys
real quick tour dates are on sale right
now at salvano comedy.com there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd the second sold
out as you guys I hopefully know uh and
so we added two shows on the first all
will be taped and all if you have a
ticket to any of those shows you'll be
eligible to win uh a flight hotel and
trip to the set of Impractical Jokers
I'm choosing one ticket out of those
four shows uh December 1st is still on
sale right now but it's going fast
salano comedy.com hope to see you guys
on the road
T the about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
tast buds man they coming to
them yeah hold on ready it's time to b a
t t l e bus Wow first first guest to
know the chant and do it with us listen
if I'm going to law school am I going to
watch suits first
probably you know who said that I like
Mike Ross and I got to tell you if I go
to buy a suit I might go to law school
first you never know and you're going to
like the way you look guaranteed you
know who said that Chandler bang was it
no no dang it what was that Men's
Warehouse yeah uh wait okay so what you
just said what you just said very
interesting and it plays into adulthood
okay because this is something that
bothered me about that book that came
out the subtle art Miss piece the subtle
art giving right it was all about this
it there was a book that came out called
the subtle art of not giving I know that
so this book comes out the orange book I
don't know but it's this but it's this
big I it you know it was this big hit
and everybody loved it and blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah right was
I heard I heard it was a big hit and
everybody loved it and then what were
the other
things what could those have been if you
what you felt the need to say it why
what are we supposed to fill in saying
blah blah it was a big
hit and all the stuff that goes along
with it everybody talked about it
everybody chat whatever I have a
specific experience with the book so
here's my point I listened to the first
chapter of it on a so funny because when
you said the book I was thinking would
you listen to it yeah I listened
literally one chapter uh I I just wasn't
very interested in it but I was curious
much like friends you should get to
chapter four before you critique the
book The book's whole thing is what
you're saying do what you want to do as
long as you're not hurting anybody
else fine fine but make sure you get the
camera switch I don't like the example
it gave and your example also I also
didn't necessarily care for like you
said about the wedding thing I'm shocked
but here's but here let me tell you why
let me tell you why all right I'm not
saying so you should go to the wedding I
understand that in certain circumstances
yes sure but part of being an adult is
saying I'm going to do something I don't
want to do for the sake of another
person that I care about yeah that's
that but that then Works directly
against what that book preaches or at
least what I gathered from the the
little I heard of it am I wrong no I
bought the book I read please go ahead I
bought the book in the airport I read a
few chapters and it wasn't taking it was
just kind of like reiterating the title
to me and I was like I'm reading I feel
like I'm reading redundancy and then I
was like maybe it's me and then I bought
the audio book so this guy's got me for
two dips into the pot and then I hav I
Haven listen to the book I never did it
right I mean I so I found the book
annoying cuz the the woman who reads it
is very like I didn't finish reading
it I'd like to speak on this I'd like to
speak on the wedding thing huh I'd like
to speak on the wedding thing yeah
please
because if you don't want to go there's
a reason you don't want to go do you not
want to go because I don't care to I'll
speak for myself do I not want to go
because I don't care to be there it's
not worth it to me or do I not want to
go because traveling takes a lot of work
and time and money but I would like to
support if it's that one yes you do the
things you don't want to do because your
intention is pure if you just go because
I don't want to I don't care to support
I'm obviously not that close to this
person well that's different but but
it's not because are you doing something
because you're supposed to because well
you're supposed to do things for other
people or you doing something because it
that's one of problems with adulthood
well yeah that this isn't this is an ad
Hood issue but look at it this way
you're with your girlfriend right she
says personal she says it would mean the
world to me it would mean the on know I
love this good good good it would mean
it would mean the world to me if once a
week when we we eat out every night if
if three of those meals uh could be in
vegan restaurants because that means
something to me and it just means a lot
to me that you show me that you're
willing to eat in a place even though
you love me and blah blah blah blah now
what does bah blah blah blah mean
sweetie what does da da da da da mean
yeah I know I know let's let's let's
ring every bit out of this bit yeah
uh I'm starting to be team you now yeah
I didn't you plagiarizing you're
plagiarizing uh Paul
Abdul you could you could say very
easily I get nothing out of going to the
vegan hold on but don't if you want to
ask a question or you want to say
something don't give me multiple choice
I'm not giving you multiple choice then
what can I say I'm giving you breakdown
I'm saying you could easily say you
could easily say I don't care about the
vegan restaurant there's no reason for
me to go there I get no enjoyment out of
that's a or right I could say
B in which one of those where you don't
go to the vegan restaurant are you doing
something that's that's not being
selfish I am going to adulthood is
confusing it is easy child I'm going to
take your point and remove all the
leading statements because if the girl
friend said hey let's do I uh you should
do vegan 3 days a week my feeling would
be very different than if she said hey
Rick it would mean something to me if we
could do this cuz then I'm doing it for
her because she's asking and she's
telling me a want and a need that's what
I'm saying so yes I could but her
reasoning for it cuz I want you to show
me
B I'm out I'll do it not to show you
that I'll do it I'm not going to go to
the wedding to prove to anybody anything
I'm going to go because show me yes you
did run it back I said it would mean a
lot to me if if you could come and show
me that just because you don't eat vegan
wedding are you doing the Macarena or
the electric
slide show me was poor show me the
Electric Slide ding ding ding show me
was poor wording show me is poor wording
but let's let's get let's just get to
the broader argument of this but you but
if you care about the person you will
want to do for them yeah but you can't
if the person at the wedding cared a lot
it would be different than if they gave
me an invitation and I'm G to go there
and I'm gonna say five words to care I
care about a lot of people in my family
and a lot of friends awesome they have
many of them have had destination
weddings that cost a lot of money and
are a pain in the ass I that tracks am
furious about it but I go yeah it's your
family there or friends but there are
people in that that take the stance that
you're saying that would say you don't
have to go you don't have to that's the
we're talking about autonomy I'm not
saying it wouldn't be nice it's about
the have to it's about starting to
resent your relationships because they
feel like obligations sometimes it is
important you do have to I have to step
forward to see you you have to step
forward to see me and it's not that
black and white adulthood is a mental
prison it is none of this exists in
childhood none of it I wake up I play I
eat I [__] play You're fool you're a
dumb fool that doesn't understand life
it doesn't understand that it can be
snatched away from you any it's when I'm
I don't have to over the the thing that
happened when I which I don't even feel
like an adult but you I overthink
everything it's to the point of Oblivion
you do you do you do we do right not you
I that is tagged that is tagged onto
adulthood immediately and it never goes
away and the you gain more and more
responsibility granted do you have more
experiences yes in every facet yes but I
find myself you keep going all these
great things yes it's fantastic yes you
get to come all the time yes you
literally get to own arcades sure so now
I said those 200 things now no no but
like I I as an adult I find myself
Longing To Be A Child again when it was
so much simpler when my life was not my
universe was smaller and more contained
I was able to enjoy moments and people
better I understand I understand you're
talking about a paradoxal paradoxical
paradoxal how you say you just blew it
dude uh whatever whatever aru you just
revealed you weren't really a lawyer how
do you say Paradox how do you say
Paradox is an
adjective paroda like pterodactyl
pterodactyl you're dealing with
Dinosaur uh old people are dinosaurs not
like children no here's the thing why is
it a parap pants it's a paradox oh God
look at look at me what's the deal stop
it hey one two it's really simple people
are really making a meal out of that
that's a pair of pant legs no it's a
pant leg
and a pair of pants which includes the
leg legs is like the one in front of the
X it's assumed a pair of shoes too
interesting about Rick is Rick is is
both sides of this argument he's the
adult side that can explain things like
an adult but then the child like with
zero attention span no matter what you
say what did you say God what did you
just say you're both sides of the
argument what what was the thing you
just said that you could explain like
the adult let me see that for a second
first B yeah there you go but here's
wait wait wait wait wait you go back you
go back let me say the go back let me
say the Paradox thing let me say the
Paradox thing no you wouldn't go back
that's good merch no hold on hold on let
me say the Paradox thing I'm not saying
eliminate your experience I I understand
watch the Kick the Can episode of The
Twilight Zone that's what the entire
episode's about it's about old people in
the last stage of their life in a home
where life has lost all luster and all
fun and whatever because they were so
busy doing things they didn't want to do
unlike a kid and an old man comes in in
the movie version It's he's played by
Scatman kers in the original I don't
remember who plays him well you're going
to say one we need to know let's put
this
out and look up the other one and old
man comes in and he says I can teach you
how to be young again and he makes them
children he makes them children again
and they play Kick the Can and that's
how they transform into kid transform
back into kids and then in the morning
they become adults again and he said
says if you want this I can give it to
you and all of them but one say I can't
do it all again even knowing what I know
now like I can't go back and do it all
you said if you could go back would you
that's literally what you do it all
again I'm not talking about a life I'm
just talking about what is a better time
you said if you could go back the did
you mean let's not argue the
misunderstanding let's not argue the
misunder attaching semantics you know
what maybe he'll say he could have used
a better choice of words you could
empathize with that but what was your
question then you said if you would you
go back does that not mean and be a kid
again well I just explained I don't mean
live my whole life again I just mean
that despite everything I've experienced
as an adult I think I was happier as a
child take us to the vote humle pie here
we go I think childhood might take it I
saw a lot of comments as he was
scrolling uh and it's not good that he's
putting
clicking we got 7,000 votes
o oh you idiots but you know but you
know but no hold on but there's
something interesting about this one
that you don't get that
often we didn't really sample the jury
properly because the percentage of this
that are adults thinking the grass was
greener then if if children that's why I
think we need to get more children to
follow you on social if
children oh [__] I have to wait seven
years to get my dick suck yeah they
would be saying the other way well perc
break down those of you
listening the percentage breakdown by
the way when you when you found the VHS
that your uncle had and and you put it
in you know that's also mind-blowing
everything's an 11 everything the cookie
the friend the rock everything 11 right
now there's es and fls to it and 11 is
literally is a tough one I think this is
a lot of people going I have a kid and I
love my kid and I watch my kid this is
adult voting think it's a lot of parents
voting in that respect we've probably
had skewed things I mean look but is it
it's 64 for those listening childhood
one 64.5% to
35.5% how much of that we can tabulate
to be what's the record this season this
is coming back on me that like the
sample are people that are just from one
thing yeah yeah yeah folks do you like
to go to events live events concerts
Theater comedy shows sporting events
whatever it is I do and I'm sure you do
too uh here's the problem the damn
ticket buying I can't stand it uh which
is why I like game time game time is
making buying those tickets a lot uh
more of a of a
stressfree if you will experience uh I
hate buying tickets in advance I hate
not knowing that I'm getting the right
deal I hate to not know what it's going
to look like from where I'm sitting but
game time is alleviating all of those
concerns and worries and just bringing a
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
events what what whatever they may be
that you want to attend that's your
business that ain't my business uh with
killer last minute deals all in prices
they show you views from your seats and
it's a best price guarantee they they
take all the guest work out of buying
tickets uh I really like that um there's
uh Allin prices that show you the total
of the ticket up front also so you know
because sometimes you see a ticket price
then you go to buy it and then there's
all these fees whatever they they're
showing you the all in price immediately
from the jump uh so you know the exact
deal which will be a great deal that
you're getting before you check out and
of course if you find tickets in the
same section and row for less money game
time will credit you 110% of the
difference uh if you find that after
you've already purchased your tickets
through them so download the game time
app and take the guess work out of
buying tickets with game time you're
going to get that app you're going to
create an account you're going to use
promo code taste buds for $20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code taste buds t
a s t bu U DS for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed folks it's the holiday
season and it's time to be making those
phone calls and those texts and all
those things we do with our cell phones
your mobile plan is going to play a big
part of your holiday season and that's
why I am recommending
mintmobile give yourself the gift of
insane savings this holiday season with
mint Mobile's best wireless deal of the
year they already have great deals but
this is the best one they've had of the
year right now here it is when you
switch to mintmobile and buy any
three-month plan you'll get another
three months for free that is nuts uh
that's six months of Premium Wireless
services for the price of three and
their prices are already outstanding
mint mobile lets you order and activate
from home while saving tons on phone
plans that start at are you ready for
this they start at just $15 a month I
can't think of a better gift than
turning an overpriced Wireless bill into
just 15 bucks a month and how do you do
it with mint mobile all right by going
online and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mintmobile passes
significant savings on to you and all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G
Network so for a limited time by any
three-month mint Mobile plan and get
three months more free by going to
mintmobile.com tastebuds that's
mintmobile.com tastebuds cut your
wireless bill to $15 a month at
mintmobile.com
tastebuds all right we got to get to
this battle we're we're we're spending a
lot of time over here uh I I know I'm
curious to see how many votes this
actually gets but s's wanted to do this
battle for a long time I'm not trying to
[__] on it
but but but we can't say you're curious
to see how many votes it gets I just
mean no no I'm saying that because I'm
curious see how much fans I'm curious to
see if anybody gives a [__] about this
battle what do you mean it's a it's a
battle just like anything else we've
done we've done pool verse ocean that
that's got some we've done fork for
spoon yeah all right I mean it's babe
it's a thing I hear you it's a is it is
for me a quintessential battle they're
the only two wait pet we you got to say
what it is it's pencil versus it's
pencil vers pen guys yeah they everybody
uses them
everybody across
all all countries all ages all barriers
okay and they're the only two things
really I mean unless you're dip in your
pen and some and and some in some
Fountain ink and doing calligraphy uh
this is what you use okay right every St
I mean come on and and and and they are
each
other's all right they're each other's
what would I what would you call it yin
and yang yeah yeah this is an excellent
excellent they complete they complete
one another yeah for a non food battle I
think you can't get a more perfect
matchup than a pen versus a pencil when
there's only two when only two things
exist in a
space I mean it's it's it's like it's
it's it's like a
Thunderdome well it depends on what that
space is but you know I say this is
what's going to be tough I got I gotta
write can you can you write can I gotta
write something I don't want people to
be like ah erasable
pen so let me just because that's what
they're GNA do wait you can edit it
after you put it up uh I maybe now on
the new one I I'm actually just going to
write a comment right on E all right
write a comment I think you can you
might be right no no no you can't you
can't I don't think you can you can you
can edit after it's posted 30 minutes
wow that's a new feature on Twitter so
Elon did do a one or two good things
over there I I thought you could how do
I do
it this is a first ever update of the
poll in real time on the show all right
just put just quote tweet it just quote
tweet it erasable pen doesn't count
tweet it won't show up for the people
that look at it so I'm just going to put
it as the next response all right
erasable pen does not count uh I mean
look I uh will say as you do that I
think the one gray area uh we
potentially didn't consider how do you
spell erasable erase enable because it's
not coming up as a word just just just
put pen with eraser doesn't count or
something there was nothing worse than
the erasable pen when I was a kid we can
both agree on that yeah when I was a kid
I thought it was the coolest thing and
you learn is it's [__] ink yeah sh it
doesn't stick to the page it's terrible
uh I also think that we're people might
if if
artists are going to
go well there's colored there's there's
a there's a colored marker there's a
there's a brush there's a you know but
but I think what obviously we're talking
about here is is a writing utens yeah uh
let's let's uh all right let's start the
battle uh it's time to be at buds uh I
am team pen Sal is team pencil uh
there's not even a contest here this is
absurd that you would even I have all
the things I love about the pencil and I
have the things that I you know I'm
going to hit you I'm G to just I'm going
to hit you with the with an argument
ending right at the top Point okay a
pen you can give the gift of a pen have
you ever received a weighted absolutely
a weighted pen I've received both I got
one in my bag of awesome one time one of
my one of my sorry my box of awesome I
got a weighted golden pen it sits
perched on my desk it looks like the
sort of Excalibur you you you you take
it off the thing and you sign something
with it you feel like you feel like
Scrooge or or or or Jimmy Stewart in a
It's a Wonderful Life it feels so
official it's incredible I've gotten a
pen as a gift actually Q gave me a pen
as a gift one time uh and I've also
gotten no joke gift for a friend to give
a weird gift he's we give each other so
much
a pen I'd be upset no it was
a it's it was the one that he loves
writing with and we write so it was a
nice it was my go-to pen at that but I I
I've been given a pen but I also have
been given a pencil and I don't mean the
traditional pencil it's just wonderful
really beautiful pencil and it's inside
like this sterling silver sheath and
it's got like a screw the the Eraser is
a screw that comes off and on the flip
side of that inside of it is a sharpener
and it's it just was beautiful actually
got it from Comedy Central in uh so then
but then it sharpens down and you're
done well you could buy another brand of
that pencil and put it in there or any
penc any pencil but this is was an
upscale I looked it up the pencil was
like upwards of $200 the only thing and
it's it's a wooden pencil it's a wooden
but it's in a sterling silver you hold
weight it's weight you hold it in the
sheath to write I mean the only thing
that comes out is the bottom I see what
you're saying so it's a pen it's a
pencil trying to do with the weighted
pen No it's it's just a it's just a
pencil uh an Innovative pencil well but
that you put your own pencil nothing
about it is a pen the only thing that
constitutes a pen is Inc my friend this
had lead and an eraser but I'm saying
you you buy a number two pencil and put
it inside this case no no it came with
its own pencil from that company so then
you got you buy a replaceable pencil and
put it in yes although you could put
anything in there I I should I'll bring
it on what happens when the pencil gets
shorter and it doesn't fit inside the
case anymore it does how it's the way it
was mechanism that keeps pushing it
Forward toothpaste style yeah it was the
way it's a designed and I'll tell you
another thing the what are those pencils
what are they us uh pilot Wings pilot
wings no what are they called the wings
they they they're the they're the ones
with that like broad like flat eraser
head top
head put just put like best pencils
it'll come up right
away just just scroll it's it's
where you going h no not not on here not
on here just go to just go to Google
searches Blackwing that's it the
Blackwing that pencil I I I I love them
this is what I see it's wonderful so
they have a a whole host of pen pencil
and they have every pencil writes feels
and and writes differently so you could
have like one that like writes fast one
that writes slow one that writes a
little wider or smoother one that writes
very it's it's just a it's just a
wonderful company I really like it they
sell um replaceable eraser heads too so
you don't get stuck with that empty
eraser up top with half a pencil left
like we did all through our school years
and then you chew that that's a but let
me tell you something else that's
something I loved I loved when I had a
number two pencil in high school or
grammar school and it was like down to
this and I lost the Eraser and then I
chewed it and I chew on that little
metal thing on the end oh I love it love
B into a pencil and leaving teeth marks
I always personalized pencils messages
on them I always hated pencils cuz they
always got the pressing they always
marked up all your stuff in your book
bag I'd get like a brande Babe I Got a
Brand your pencil case would look like
it went through aing trash compactor by
the end of the school year I I hated
pencils for their lack of boundaries
they just didn't know how to keep to
themselves ever ever once in a while you
get a pen that explodes sure but but oh
Joe but you here's what I see here's
what a pen explosion is is a lifetime of
lead markings inside your bag explosion
up of the pocket in this pocket on your
hands you ain't getting that off
where count I can count on one hand how
many times it has happened one hand
right so it's happened at least five
times that's horrible no no no I can
count on one hand how many times it's
happened meaning I I can remember maybe
two times that ever happened it's still
traumatic it is traumatic my point is is
with the pencil it was always a problem
it never stopped it's all I don't know
about that well this is what I'm going
to this is what I see with a pencil
you're saying marks up some things in
your I'm going to make an analogy it's
it's weak it's a weak thing I'm going to
make an analogy
yeah the pen is David
Letterman it's no it is not hold on let
me he famously used pencils let me
finish let me finish let me just say
fine Johnny Carson the pen is Johnny
Carson you don't know if it's Johnny
Carson well I would I can I I think that
Johnny Carson and David lman are the two
greatest late night hosts of all time
I'm going to go with Johnny Carson
though just to [__] your your David
Letterman pencil thing the pen is Johnny
Carson it's a professional it rules the
roost it knows it rules the roost it
comes out it's classy it doesn't need to
a pen is not classy hold on a second let
me let me finish let me finish big pen
is not nothing it has nothing it has
nothing to prove it knows what its job
is it does the job that's the end of the
day I have a lot to say now I look at
pencils I see colored pencils I see
monogrammed pencils I see pencils with
custom messages on them I see pencils
with zany pictures on them and what I
see and what I see is Conan
O'Brien someone who's good at his job
but can't turn it off tries way too hard
all the time just it just never stops 20
plus year late night vet go you go Conan
you're great at what you do
stop for a second just stop learn from
the pen for a second calling the pencil
Conan O'Brien is a compliment all right
let's go to the vote let's go to the vot
on your hands like you robbed the bank
and the bag exploded let's go to the
vote everything you just said there
every single thing every single thing
you just said there everything I had and
have an answer for every single thing
you said okay okay all right what
happens when you get a pen in your hand
can we please just go to the vote what
happens when you get a pen we pleas I
don't want to talk about this anymore I
don't want to talk about this anymore
this is psychotic terrible points this
is psychotic I think this is your worst
ever defense of an item
okay oh way better than I thought way
better than I thought 76.5 to 23.5
that's more than double what I thought
it was guess what well guess what I
still love you buddy I love you
too now I'm telling you right now I
think I think in people's opinion we got
to get salty here all right we're too
calm it's too nice I've been crying we
got to get salty all right all right
yeah yeah
yeah ready
yeah who's going first you you insult me
first you go first cuz I need to know
what your level
is uh all right ready yeah it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty grow up with the shoes
grow up yeah you're 45 years old you're
running around like Punky Brewster it's
enough shout out pun it's enough it's
enough oh wow see I thought these were I
thought these were it's enough hot like
fire as the kids it's enough you know
shoes don't make a personality you know
what I mean oh really yeah stop well I
have enough to go around of a person uh
pimp do you like him I love them I love
them obsessed love them and
obsessed one of these guys is doing his
own thing Pip's wearing a shirt that was
sewn together from two different
shirts all right yeah I V didn't know
who John Candy was so I you know I don't
know where you're going for your support
here pimp is tough to get to get
approval from clothing wise because I
just feel like he wears just just
different I I feel like he just wears
different textiles all right like his
whole thing is just take a little of
this a little of that this is a shirt
but I'm going to wear it as a pants I
know I hear you all right hit me back
ready yeah salty Sal grow up you just
told tens of thousands of people that
you cry over a goddamn
wook and you cried in front of him right
you cried in front of him over chewbaca
it's a it's it's I cried when Han Solo
died in force awakens chewbaca you cried
over Chewbacca and you just you told me
to grow up with my shoes right you can't
tell me this is at least it's is at
least fashion you agree with it you
don't you just said to me the irony grow
up with the shoes when you were wiping
away the tear that was still there from
crying over I know emotions had an age
limit okay I didn't know emotions had an
age limit I mean I mean I don't know
crying at Chewbacca though why I mean do
you wear underoo living breathing you
guys don't even know what underoo is
there was no laugh yeah no no no you
guys know what Underoos are undo were
the [__] actually if I had they still
had undo I'd get them I know they were
great yeah you know what I love under
color forms color forms but under are
clothes no I know but I would play with
color forms what about freezy freakies
bro I don't know what that is what do
you what do you what do you what do what
do you I don't know what it is it's the
gloves that when it got cold the things
would appear on them
it was literally like you couldn't get
them when we were younger it was like a
Cabbage Patch oh yeah oh I remember
those yeah oh wow right I forgot that
existed till right now how about this
they I thought of it like three four
years ago and we were going on a ski
trip and uh with Ari and a bunch of
comics whoever everybody was there and
uh I was like let me see if these I was
going to buy us old ones they re they re
brought the company back and I bought
brand new Freezy freakies for everybody
what the hell all right we got to get to
the battle yeah yeah yeah we got friends
versus Seinfeld I am taking
friends because uh well CZ South per
usual goes I I I have to take the easy
win I I didn't do that I have to take I
didn't do that at all as a matter of
fact you called me up and you go babe I
got it frasia vers Seinfeld yeah no we
did on the show on the show last week
you're going to get cream we talked
about it on the show last we were just
about to do Fraser Seinfeld I was like I
know we first when we first came out
with this it was going to be Seinfield
versus cerb right which would have been
that's that's well friends is really a
boohemoth as well though so I last time
we were on I said I can't do friends I
have to do Frasier Frasier is my
arguably my favorite sitcom of all time
so is Seinfeld arguably sure but we
crack a window just for a little bit
here's the thing V said friends is
great uh I found myself for some
reason curious after she said that
friends is friends is great I never
watched it I've been watching friends
for the last two weeks she's shocked
that you never watch friends now after
not knowing the last 10 references we've
said well she was here's why I didn't
watch friends friends came out when I
was about a senior in high
school uh you know senior year you're
not sitting home watching sick every
girl I knew though it was only watched
at that time and and I and I no I
watched Friends was friends was big
enough to it was it overcame so it was
senior year then I went into college and
you know it's party time you know and
then I started doing stand up it was
like Seinfeld didn't wrap till 98
Seinfeld came out when I was like a
freshman in high school or something
yeah that's uh and I by the way I never
watched Seinfeld when it was on I re I'd
seen it but I Revisited it uh you you
didn't watch I never watched until it
was over I watched the finale because it
was such a big event and I hated it I
hat I still don't like the finale I like
the finale and it put me off of wanting
to see any more wow that's crazy bro and
then about 7 years ago I was addicted
seven years ago or so I called shout out
Pat wasal once again and I said is
Seinfeld worth buying CU it's like 50
bucks for the whole series on Amazon
today and he was like you're insane buy
it right now oh my God and I bought it
and I watched it all the way through and
then obsessively ever since and I was
like this is probably the greatest
sitcom of all time
I used to deliver pizza and I got out at
11: but if there was no there was no
orders I could mop and clean up and get
out at about 10:45 and I lived like 7
minutes from the Pizzeria and I would
mop and clean this is for syndicated
Seinfeld at 11: p.m. just to get home
fast enough to hit record on my VHS and
I have my own Seinfeld VHS Library
there's about five six episodes per tape
and I had a marble notebook with the
episodes and the guide in the notebook
that's how much I love sign yeah no I I
hear you I should do that with the
Twilight Zone yeah before I own the
whole thing but uh the uh you s I love
Seinfeld I did the same thing with
Frasier I went back after the fact and
fell in love with it I love Frasier so
much friends in all seriousness as of
this moment of the recording of This
podcast friends is not even in my top
probably 10 sitcoms of all time because
I am less familiar with it than the
others however
given that V Peak my curiosity yeah and
I started to watch over the last two
weeks I am falling in love with it and I
feel did you watch from the beginning
yeah and I've gleaned enough now cuz I
will obsessively watching from the
beginning is tough you got to get to
like season three of any SI combo for it
I actually think season three of friends
is where it starts to get a little I
don't think that season is anywhere near
as good as one and two oh really so far
and then and it bums me out because you
can start to see you can start to see in
season 3 that they're becoming that
they're famous now yeah they start to
look better it's like the thing Rob
mhany said about when he got fat for to
Sunny he's like they just start to look
better and better and you're like oh
Jennifer Anderson like I can tell like
she was in this movie by then and like
whatever well I'll tell you I thought
what I thought you were going to say
which is one of my criticisms of
Seinfeld if I'm being fair was that if
you watch the first season like it's a
tough watch it Finds Its strid in like
there might be an episode or a moment
halfway through season 2 is where sidef
stuff right yeah it's the the washing
machine one when they go down for the
washing machine Revenge yeah and Kramer
does the whole set piece with trying to
pour the cement in yeah yeah and that
might also be the nose job one season is
that the tape the tape machine the foone
what's that answering machine one where
they go two or three I don't remember
but yeah but that's when it that's that
that that that whole yeah but I'll tell
you what Seinfeld suffered from I
thought that it became so the most
popular thing on Earth that that they
then
started the storylines came from a place
of oh we have a formula now like and
then they the the charact you have to I
guess evolved somewhow and the
characters became caricatures it was it
became a cartoon the last two two
seasons are like a cartoon maybe even
three season it's like they're doing
it's almost like they hired new writers
and the writers were like let me let me
write a Seinfeld epode from what I know
the last two seasons have some of the
best episodes and by far the worst
episodes oh it's bad like by like
there's nowhere near like two through
six there's some bangers in the last two
seasons but but overall it's very very
by the way the misses I still love like
I'm just saying in in comparison to
themselves but Seinfeld you know I mean
I'll tell you what Seinfeld and friends
have a lot of the same traits as a
sitcom you could put it on and like it
could be halfway through one and you
literally watch it because it's
instantly it instantly grabs you so for
the last two weeks I've been watching
friends at lunch and anytime I eat lunch
or dinner at home I watch it anytime I'm
working at home I have it on in the
background and then I've been going to
sleep to it so I'm I'm I'm pretty deep
into season like four at this point okay
I've I've gotten through a lot I this is
what I do I get obsessed with show oh
you don't even know that you're about
you don't know about what happens in
like the mid to later Seasons I know how
the show ends I've seen the finale
why why why that you're you're shocked
that he doesn't know the end of the show
yet I know I know how the show ends a
lot of but a lot of stuff happens
between the characters yeah they they go
through I've watched the opposite of
Seinfeld which made a promise and kept
it I know that Ross I know that Ross and
and uh uh Rachel will eventually break
up I know that Ross is going to get
married to the English woman I know that
Rachel comes back in I know that
Chandler and Monica end up together I
know the series ends with Monica and
Chandler with the babies and them
leaving and this is what I will say I
know all that cuz I've seen some of it
out of sequence over the years and like
I'm putting it together as I watch a lot
of like a lot of tumultuous things that
happen no I know I know um and some of
it I don't know but you know dude this
is where I'm at I was online last night
there's drama I was online last night
looking up Phoebe's apartment I was like
where does she live do we see it ever I
want to see now I want to see what
Phoebe's apartment looks like that's
weird that she doesn't live there
too uh anyway so um she uh anyway I will
tell you this right now and I'll say it
right off the bat as far as Landing
sticks go Seinfeld doesn't hold a
[__] candle as far as I'm concerned
to friends I already know I will
sticking the landing I will be crying my
eyes out at the end of friends the way I
do at the end of Golden Girls when they
leave that house at the end of golden
I'm like it is devastating and that's
what the end of this will be I will tell
you that
Seinfeld
lacks that kind of emotion but that is
not they build their
show promising you you will not get
emotion it will not be relationships
that you have to latch on to they will
not they they said that that was as
advertised and they stayed the course
and they were like this is just I don't
even mean the show about nothing because
it is about stuff but it's just like
they just stayed in self-contained
episodes for the most part and they St
stuck to their formula it was about
jokes was about shitty people it but
that's not what I'm talking about I am
not talking about the emotional depth of
something okay I know I said that it's I
probably sound like that's what I meant
what I meant
was and this is why I can argue friends
over Seinfeld friends I do think the
emotional Resonance of friends go
carries a lot farther than the character
characters of Seinfeld because of the
emotional depth
but it's a show that that hinges on on
the friendship and the relationship of
those characters and it lands in a place
that you feel fulfilled where those what
you saw those characters Seinfeld did
not in any in my opinion in any way
shape or form deliver a
fulfilling resolution it's it's they
become so unlikable in the last episode
they are such Petty people and they do
try to do a little [__] emotional
thing when the plane's going down Jerry
I always wanted to oh give me a [__]
break that was just a little that was a
tease and then they didn't do it it's
lame though it's a bread Crum N I will
tell you the task they have at hand
right you have you have a history of
these six characters in their
relationships in their friendships that
had an arc over all those Seasons so
when you're wrapping it up you have a
lot more invested to wrap up Seinfeld
stayed alak cart it stayed it stayed to
just we're shitty people and so you're
not going to get that kind of gravity
but here's the thing too here's the
thing too I don't agree agree that
Seinfeld was about shitty people cuz it
wasn't it was about people being
frivolous and and Petty you know what
sums it up nuanced what sums it up the
one where Elaine gets the number the
other the Bizarro friends sure Felman
from across the hall yeah when she tells
Jerry she can't hang out with them
anymore the way she describes their
hangout that was later on though I know
but she says she goes I can't keep
coming to this apartment pouring over
everything little stupid thing about
life or whatever that to me is what the
show was about it was about people that
had absolute curb it's yeah it's but but
it's minua but here's the thing by the
end of Seinfeld yeah they're they don't
even care about each other anymore it's
there's there's a camaraderie with
Seinfeld in the contest the the the
pinky you know the pinky bet whatever
how they do it they have a they're a
team and they get each other's backs and
they help each each other through their
problems and they fight and whenever
they're real friends let's go to the
phones because got to I got to peie so
bad I got to piece so bad let's get the
vote pie episode roll it out percentages
all right this is going to be how how do
you how many votes 10,000 that's it so
far I thought people would jump on that
because the nature of it about 10,000 in
an hour is not bad all right the winner
with 56% oo that's close bro very close
that's very close Seinfeld 56% though
that is that is very close that's very
close we knew it would be close great
wow that was that was very close i y you
I don't think anyone would I still love
you I love you
too folks let's talk about prize picks
prize picks is the largest daily fantasy
sports platform DFS daily fantasy sports
in North America the largest DFS
platform in North America they are the
easiest and most exciting way to play
DFS and it's just you you against the
numbers instead of battling thousands of
players including the pros or the sharks
or whatever you pick more than or less
than on two to six player stat
projections and watch the winnings roll
in I like prize picks for this reason I
don't like things where I gotta go with
the group and I gotta compete against
the group and whatever I I don't like
that I like the way prize picks is doing
this I wish everything in life was like
this uh with basketball season here you
can now pick combo projections Ross
football and basketball from the
specials League a league created
specifically for combo projections that
includes two or more players from
different sports or leagues for example
LeBron James and Travis Kel is it Kel is
it Kelsey folks I don't know sports but
I know that prize picks makes it easy
for me to participate and that's even a
guy like me can enjoy it all right uh
anyway you can pick those two players at
a 10 .5 combo of three points made plus
receptions you see what I'm saying I
think you see what I'm saying uh if you
want to play alongside also of some of
prize pick's favorite players like
rapper Meek Mill and comedian Andrew
Schultz friend of mine uh Schultz not
Meek Mill I I hope to meet me Mill one
day maybe I'll meet him through prize
picks anyway now you can find Community
plays under the promos tab of the app to
view entries from some of the biggest
names in the prize pick Community each
week prize pick even offers a reboot
policy so that your entries stay in play
even if one of your players gets injured
so for uh football and basketball games
if you have a player who exits the game
in the first half and does not return in
the second half that player can be
rebooted like video game style prize
picks is the only daily fantasy sports
platform with injury insurance policy
all right listen I want you to go to
prize picks I want you to give it a shot
okay like I said even a dumb dumb like
me when it comes to sports has has used
it and had a great time using it and if
you like sports it's going to be even
more fulfilling and enth and exciting so
go to prize.com tastbuds and use code
tastebuds for a first deposit match up
to
$100 I'll say it again go to prize.com
tastebuds and use code tastebuds for a
first deposit match up to
$100 all right prize picks daily fantasy
sports made
easy folks this episode of taste buds is
sponsored by
betterhelp better help's been with us
for a very long time and there's a
reason for that we really like what
they're offering the people that are
subscribing to their service okay better
help okay let's talk about this time of
year uh this time of year can be very
stressful not just because of all the
holiday stuff that's happening uh but
because of just basically the the
pressures that come along with it I I
for one feel pressures uh during this
time of year to not only see all the
people that uh in my life that I care
about that I want to see but also to
attend a lot of different events that
are related most of them to the holidays
but then also to get in all of my
personal interests and and doings done
before the real cold weather hits uh
that's my experience as somebody living
on the East Coast it gets a little
stressful and then the anticipation of
the winter being on its way of the new
year starting trying to get off on the
right foot in the New Year it's a lot
it's a lot this time of year can be a
lot and it's natural to feel some
sadness or anxiety about it so by adding
something new or positive to your life
you can counteract some of those
feelings that's where therapy has helped
me a great deal therapy has been a
bright spot for me it has helped me talk
through some of these anticipatory
anxieties and real-time anxieties that
I'm having uh and it gives me therapy
gives me something to look forward to
meaning the session itself where I can
speak to my therapist and I know that
I'm going to come out of that feeling a
little more
grounded a little more prepared and a
little more equipped with the tools that
I need to manage everything that is
going on I have benefited greatly in
life from therapy but I have also at
times found therapy entering back into
it uh and some of you might feel this
entering into for the first time it's a
it could be daunting because of all of
the different things you need to tackle
first what better help is here to
alleviate all of that and give you a
very convenient a very flexible uh and a
very suited to your schedule approach to
therapy and it's also super super easy
to get started that is so important you
go and fill out a brief questionnaire
you get match with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no addition charge and they're
offering uh great rates for all this
stuff I'm telling you people if you
started thinking about therapy give
betterhelp a try find your bright spot
this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds today to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com tastebuds time to B A TL ebds all
right it's dark meat versus white meat
me and marker team dark meat Sal's team
white meat couple of dark over here yes
take it easy all right take it easy and
then we got a you know white see off to
the left yeah tried to balance it out
did you
yes uh I uh I here's the thing can't
believe you prefer white meat it's
insane well I just think it just is
juicier and it is more appealing hit
when I have look this is how I know I
don't like dark me you're floundering
cuz I was not even looking at what what
type of chicken I was eating a couple of
months ago and I was like oh this is why
does this taste like this and then I
looked and it was dark meat and I was
like oh I guess I don't like dark meat
this is it's what I told you before it's
what I imagine dog meat to taste like
you're using this dog can I just say
you're using this dog example a lot
lately you said it about hummus too wet
dog no hummus tastes like edible throw
up but you said wet dog with hummus as
well like you used the wet well then
maybe those two things you know wet dog
but I'm just saying you're going to dog
a lot recently oh twice so but uh anyway
two times but let's call let's call you
know just stop depress two times in a
short period of time um do you ever are
you ever eating something sometimes
happens to me with sushi I love sushi
but once in a
while I just go I smell it and taste it
and all of a sudden I'm repulsed by it
even though I kind of like it I'm like
what am I doing I'm chewing on this I
know what you mean chicken it's been
happening to me lately where like
normally I eat chicken chicken tastes
like chicken I don't even pause I I know
what it's about to taste like it tastes
like that sure not even not even two
weeks ago I ate a piece of chicken and I
could couldn't even finish it because I
was like this tastes
like flesh of a chicken I don't know
what it is it just I was chewing I'm
like all of a sudden during The Chew I
was like I don't like I was eating a
piece of chicken once and I got freaked
out cuz you on the skin you could see
like the bumps from where the feathers
got plucked out and I was like and I was
like oh my God and it like really rra me
out and I couldn't eat anymore it makes
it real yeah so yeah that's uh that that
happens but what does that have to do
with white meat or dark well the taste
of dark meat is that brings that out for
me exct I start chewing I'm like oh this
tastes like I it tastes like it's not
civil it tastes like what we haven't
come a long way cooking food I just I'm
like oh this tastes like I'm eating a
chicken so you have a drumstick in your
hand and you're going oh this is
repulsive I mean everybody loves a
drumstick I mean I got to tell had a
drumstick I feel like the argument ends
there the drumstick that's it I mean the
drumstick you it's it's the it's the
emoji for chicken yes it's the piece of
chicken you think of any you think of
fried chicken you think of KFC you think
Papa anything you think of chicken hey
you want chicken for dinner in your head
in the cartoons the guy's head turns
into a drumstick how about those big
turkey drumsticks at the Super Bowl they
Thanksgiving those are the best they're
awesome the Viking one yeah I get that
but but the thing so wait no drumstick
has white meat none none no that's dark
me no only the only a now a chicken wing
is white meat so if you get hot wings
the drumstick in the hot wings is white
meat no a true drumstick is the leg of
the chicken connects to the thigh
chicken quarter if you will when they're
still connected together I love the
quarter oh God I mean it's let me ask
you this is there darker meat than dark
is it levels of
dark because you know what do you mean
no like no no sing like are there parts
of the chicken that it's like let's
picture it on a scale a gradient like a
spectrum right like is there like like
okay this is kind of dark meat but this
is like really dark meat like if the
drumstick is like here but then another
it's dark and white so so so what color
is dark meat to you cuz I see but I will
I will say that that some of the white
meat is uh a bit fattier than like the
breast is the non-fatty part of the
chicken right okay pretty much that's
why breast meat so often is so dry when
you do it right though but but just hear
my point you you don't get a dry Wing
yeah you know what I mean like you've
never you've rarely had hot wings and
gone like these are dry covered in wet
sauce right well but I just mean when
you bite into it right because it's a
fattier type of white meat uh but like
the the the breast is is that's that's I
mean it's like fat free basically I
think I don't believe there's any F yeah
if you take the skin off it is yeah like
yeah that's I delicious it can be yeah
it can be what color is dark meat
it might be just a hair darker what
color is it grayish that's disgusting I
would say gray it's offwhite but isn't
it also like red and like isn't it like
a bunch of different colors like no but
some's light gray and some's like way
darker than the gray and some's like has
like that pinkish red no what you're
thinking of is the fact that the dark
meat pieces are much less meaty and
closer to the Bone a breast has no bone
in it except for the very bottom part so
when you cut into a breast you're seeing
a consistent color because there's no
bone obstructing it you cut into a thigh
there's literally a bone going through
the middle of it right the bone around
the bone is where the blood is and stuff
that's why they say chicken they say
chicken if you're eating it and you see
blood as long as the blood's near the
bone it's fine it's safe I mean you for
me this is strikes against you it's not
strikes against blood it's about proper
you see blood it's okay it just has to
be close to the Bone well you like a
bloody steak red or dark meat is made up
of muscles with fibers that are called
slow twitch these muscles are used for
extended periods of activity work
walking standing meat all right then red
sure uh but I mean
listen yeah Mark makes a great Point
since when is blood and meat a bad thing
I mean a bloody if you serve me a steak
and it's not bleeding I'm going to throw
it but not in
chicken yes chicken properly
cook on your chicken drum sck chicken
should not usually have blood they're
saying if you're eating chicken and you
happen to see some blood near the bone
it's don't panic and in your mind that
this dark meat is what it's it's tast
your why it's got got way more flavor
what are you tasting more of and it's
juicier it's not tasting more of
something it's like it's it's a 100%
juicier 100% juicier it's not about your
tasting have you ever had the experience
I had where you're eating not even let's
not even call chicken at first but like
you're eating something and you're like
I know that this is supposed to taste
like this but all of a sudden this
tastes like I'm in my head about how
this tastes yes I already said that I
understood ribs especially cuz you're
like this is a rib cage that's when I
got [__] up yes yes okay so that's
what happens to me when I have when I
have dark meat has it never happened to
you with chicken I literally told a
story where it happened to me two
minutes ago I said that exact thing
happened to me I told the whole story
and you went okay I don't remember that
but the record you're in
the see where the PLU were came out oh
no but I'm not talking about the taste
bro you mean just the taste itself yeah
yeah the taste like I just like what I
said well I don't think ooh ooh but
that's all I said it was the taste I
don't think the taste you're not saying
The Taste you're I like the taste no no
no I fat has taste you're saying when
something hold on hold on you he he's
saying he asked about when you get
freaked out by a food halfway through
you're not saying because of the taste
you're saying the idea that it's a rib
cage I'm saying cuz I could could see
the feather marks you're saying the
literal literal taste I mean I think
that could have happened to you with
white meat too I don't see how that
pertains to dark or white meat chicken
like you're it but it happens all the
time with the dark
meat it just
feels I feel like I'm eating a chicken
when I'm eating the dark meat white meat
all the way dark meat looks like the
inside of Joe's heart black and full of
hate there go curveball cards LLC yeah
there you go uh got to give them the
love I I don't you're telling me S when
you eat fried chicken you get a bucket
of delicious Fried Chicken from your
favorite fried chicken drumstick first
you're telling me you don't eat those
drumsticks and thighs I think maybe in
fried chicken maybe we got to get some
fried chicken up here yeah I think for I
think for fried chicken I don't know if
I discriminate in any way shape or form
with the meat but I do know that I've I
don't like dark meat outside of that
maybe at least it just it freaks me out
also when you're cutting it and stuff
and you I don't know just outside of
outside of a outside of a Chick-fil-A
Sandwich which is a grand slam sandwich
and white meat okay I will admit to that
I would tell you that I think white meat
chicken is is the most boring food on
planet Earth I won't cross the street
for a fried chicken breast when I get
fried chicken I say I only want legs and
thighs who the only time if I'm ordering
in a restaurant that I'll eat like that
I eat uh white meat chicken I'm pretty
sure is if I get like I'll get wings I
like wings I don't dislike I don't
dislike white meat but I find the only
preparations of it that make it enjoy
it it it's got to be doused in like a
cream sauce or what you know or you got
to or you got to do a hammered chick
like a chicken cutlets great but you're
hammering that thing so thin and
covering it and breading and then
basically deep frying it you know
like you know these are talk to me about
Thanksgiving okay I love that turkey leg
Yeah that turkey leg I love but again
I'll do the white beat if it's covered
in gravy and I get a scoop of stuffing I
get a scoop scoop of green beans with
turkey outside of lunch meat forget it
the white meat offends me on
Thanksgiving and I get pissed if that's
all that's left like the Native
Americans oh dude I put that dark meat
down cuz you can taste the white meat
through all the other stuff you put that
dark meat down and the the the juiciness
and the grease and the stuffing and the
gravy by the way you're not getting
gravy without dark meat it looks like it
looks like dolphin meat gravy's coming
from the fat baby
hard now we're talking great Point uh
all right here's the vote Humble Pie we
got 7,000
votes let's go wow I told you man we're
in the
minority right drum roll we got the
white meat winning with 59.5 to a 40.5
we got trounced yeah that's not that's
not too bad you've see we' said we've
had some 9010 oh wow really so not too
bad even after all those great diet
tribes you had yeah I know that's yeah
what are you going to do whates it say
to you though that the collective masses
agree that white meat is better why it
says what I've always said about the
collective masses they're dumb dull and
boring and have no taste or aesthetic uh
concept so the 59.5% of the 7,000 votes
that's all of them yeah every last one
of them fair enough that's all I need
you to say I still love you babe love
you too all right guys uh here's the
battle ilos versus Hot Pockets I am Team
Hot Pockets the other three gentlemen in
the room are ilos now I know I might
lose with this and pimp asked me before
why might Hot Pockets is a is a is a is
a Goliath I just think they are huge
yeah but people love ilos but pimp asked
me before the show why you like Hot
Pockets I said pimp I got to be honest
with you I'm not crazy about Hot Pockets
but I hate I like fight I hate ilos even
as a kid I never once ever had a moment
in my life where I like ilos where I
thought it tasted good I never talked to
anyos where the Box looked attractive to
me from the box to the product to the to
the way it's wrapped in that shitty
plastic what's crazy is everything
you're saying is what I love about what
I love about I love the box I love the
three perforated slices three on three9
in the Box I slot it out I pour right in
that toaster oven let me tell you
something right now I'm a pizza kid okay
I I I grew up around Pizza I love pizza
I deliver pizza for 5 years almost and I
seek out good pizza I know good pizza
I'm from Staten Island I eat good pizza
all the time something about ilo's pizza
you might say you know oh it's it's it's
you know it's crap it's frozen it's
Bargain Basement it's [__] it's this
and that it's like how you like and I
know I want to bring this up cuz but
it's like the McDonald's burger right
it's not the best burger but there's
something about it that tastes it and
people get addicted to it I think ilos
is so goddamn good I think the sauce is
good the she I love
it's simple there's no they only have
the only the only thing they I think
they offer just pepperoni no
no audacity to start trying to put
toppings on this crap oh you're nuts
there [__] on a shingle they serve and
they call it Pizza they started put meat
toppings on it I can't imagine how bad
the meat is they can't even get the
cheese sauce and bread right sorry hold
on hold you're defending pocket meat
that meat is coming right there oh get
the get out of here they might even be
owned by the same company take that
shove it up your ass oh Joe you just
can't you can't talk about the toppings
on anos that's going right it's going
right into
your you a Hot Pocket I never I I will
say I've had Hot Pockets in my life but
I honestly believe I've had 10 in my
life listen as a guy who went through a
big phase of HPS uh they are good for
what they serve on the Run maybe I was
more of a lunch and dinner late night
guy the on I get it I do get it but it's
not a real food at least the pizza the
frozen pizza may not be the best hot
where else do you get a a version of a
hot Pock wait a minute it's a made up
you mean you mean you mean the con the
concept the construction of it it's a
it's a kzone what do you mean where do
you get a version of that it's a kzone
it's cheese and meat inside of bread
they got a steak and cheese one they got
a ham and cheese one they got a
pepperoni sauce and cheese one what was
Hot Pockets were in 209 in 2020 and 21
glass and plastic fragments yeah sounds
like great meat okay so so so so two
people found plastic in their Hot
Pockets over the course of three days
come on come on guys this is weak you
you're better than this you're better
than this you're better than this no
than he's the Cal he's good the czone
the czone I thought I had him dead the
rights on they don't exist you mind let
me let me just take a step back sure but
why not call it czone czone is not hot
pockets is fun but pizza's Pizza
calzone's czone no but Hot Pockets is
fun go ahead Foley we I mean I just
wanted to go back on the first of all
they're not owned by the same company
one's manufactured in Kentucky and the
other one uh is loai New Jersey oh wow
local boys talking about the packaging
are you kidding me I hate the ilos
packaging do what in the hot pocket
space shoot you got to put it into can
supposed to be a microwave that thing's
crazy no when I stick it in a little you
got to stick it in a GL case and put it
in the microwave hold on the packaging I
meant the box I'm just saying I hate
every aspect of ilos but it I was you
mentioned the plastic on I was saying
down that looks like a box of Muffler
down to the plastic because here's the
thing when you get most frozen pizza
when you get it and you take it out out
of its packaging or whatever if it comes
in a box or whatever usually it's on
some sort of platter it's shrink wrapped
it's it's packaged in a certain way when
you get ilos it is put into these loose
baggies the cheese has fallen off of it
inside of the plastic I
mean I'm going to tell you I'm going to
tell you why but I'm going to wait
that's going to be the coup gr the nail
say sprinkle the cheese a little bit of
a rope a do here yeah I really give it
to him but you got to you get let me
guess you get to kick out of sprinkling
the bag the bag remnants on the top of
the pizza I actually never did that when
I was a kid really no you do look how
good that looks it's so good dude the
Box looks like Italy you got the red you
got the green there's garden vegetables
on there it looks fresh it looks fun
look at that actually invented by
Italians by proper off thebat Italians
that's beautiful yeah 1963 ilos pizza
was founded in Long Island New York town
of Great Neck by Elias betsos George
leis and Manny why it looks like Greek
people you just were in Greece let me
tell you my experience with alios every
time I ate it it was mushy it was FL
user eror you put it in yeah thank you
user ER it was
flavorless uh the cheese has t the
cheese melts on it I hate the way the
chees it never has it never has enough
cheese it never has enough cheese and
the cheese is shredded too thin and too
sparsely uh uh uh sprinkled on top that
you don't get enough Cheese look at that
that's if I got that slice in a
restaurant or a pizeria I'd be like can
I you're a restaurant a Hot Pocket in a
restaurant Bo I would burn it the [__]
down I would say I would say guys
where's the cheese there's no cheese on
this if they served me a Hot Pocket as a
calzone I'd punch him in the mouth
that's true that's
true so what you're saying what what
you're saying AR so you prefer a
screaming hot side of a Hot Pocket with
an ice cold center with a shitty
popcorn never had an ice cold Center
baby not once not once not once not true
because unless you have the greatest
microwave in the history of mic
times has the hot pocket saved your ass
on the road you come back to that hotel
at 3: a.m. everything is closed you walk
to that Lobby Little convenience shelf
and they got the freezer with hot
pockets in it and you go I can have
dinner now never never [__] go I the
shower cap before I atat the Hot Pocket
you're full of [__] never I'd rather
have a 7-Eleven Frozen cheeseburger than
a hot how about shots fired that's nuts
how about that also the only op you're
forced to cook it if you're then you're
cooking in the lobby of a Best Western
like a jerk off you get a bag of chips
and you go home yeah that's in the room
hey say drop the fries for table three
you're like you got chips you got a
Nature Valley honey oats got microwave
in the room bag of cash microwave in the
room some smart food don't act like you
don't know what I'm talking about I've
seen the first class pictures don't act
like you still
no that's a shitty that's a motel if
it's got a that's to crack no they
usually put a microwave in a coffee
machine a little in a little fridge in
every hotel room that's pretty standard
stuff
iave yeah you might be sleeping at a
7-Eleven now I think about it let me
tell you something about let me let me
tell something what you said about the
cheese I know what you mean because
you're speaking of Pizza in general but
some people might like something about
ilos they everything they do even if it
is slightly less on the cheese still
works for me it it it is so specific of
what it is and I like the sauce I don't
feel like I'm getting jipped on cheese I
feel it's the perfect amount of
everything I accept it as is and I like
it exactly the way it is they have extra
cheese Elios by the way so that whole
debate is out you can just buy extra
cheese well okay but hold on a second
that debate is not out because they
didn't have extra cheese Elios when we
were growing up and just because they
have it now doesn't mean elos is
suddenly good we are talking about the
core the the the the original ilos you
put did you what's the original Hot
Pocket if you don't mind me asking I
would say say the two originals are the
ham and cheese and the
pepperoni I'll give that the pepperoni
pizza I'll give you that just so know I
also agree that the quality of both of
those has dipped off in recent years
however uh that's not true you don't
think so hot pocket yes elos no cuz I
ate a [__] ton of I'm saying the quality
of the Hot Pocket yes has the hot pocket
have say hot pocket was a higher when it
first came out right I'll give you that
okay so that's a bummer to me that it's
dipped off but I will say you want to
talk about being a kid enjoying
something after school what was better
than your mom having in a freezer a
thing that you cooked and and was a hot
it felt like you were having like a real
meal or something after school it was so
elevating me elev nobody thought that
was a real meal no thought that was
elevated elev when you're 11 it's
awesome all right by the way get the
tickets now you're show out all over
yeah shows are selling out so great
check out the taste buds merch go to
noes network.com uh you know subscribe
on YouTube and no press uh follow us on
Spotify rate US on iTunes please we we
haven't been saying that for a while but
we could really use it hit that like
button hit that alert button my tickets
are on sale uh my yes our tickets are on
sale joa.com right y salano comedy.com
my special taping at the Vic in Chicago
on December 2nd is on sale right this
second if you want to get that and uh
yeah that's pretty much it let's go to
the phones here pimp is taking ilos drum
roll
oo all right okay I will say how does
that match up close wise are they
typically that close or that's decent
that's a decent battle B especially
since people don't know iOS 40s
especially that that only tells me that
elos did
outperformed we're fighting we're
fighting a national brand yeah we got
Hot Pockets guys for the listeners we
got hot pockets in a 56.4% and ilo's
Pizza in a
43.6% we'll take it I'll take it I
didn't know that uh
ilos because of the te I don't think it
is regional it is it's only the
Northeast but how did they get teenage
mut Ninja Turtles is a part of it it's
such a good product but you know what
sayal a lot of little Philly dirt bags
are
watching it could have just been a
regional ads though like hey we'll have
this one we'll have one in the South one
in the west I just feel like if I just
feel like that's a wild uh get yeah you
know but I guess Al you know sha does
insurance commerci comms that are
Regional to like
Atlanta anyway folks we I still love all
three of
you taste buds they come to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to them